let's get this camera set Bertha
everything's recorded nobody could
betray me and there's absolutely nothing
that can go wrong that's for sure cuz
it's all in tune right that's right
Donald
hey buddy when you watch this tape
remember that you set these cameras up
and don't get scared
hi this is Elizabeth Warren and I need
two pizzas and I want it sent to my home
address which is two to two Cherokee
Drive Pocahontas Massachusetts an
ominous I don't see what the big deal is
kids love being separated from their
families it's like camp a -
[Music]
ammo - frustrate parts of his agenda and
his worst inclinations I should know sir
I was writing your memoirs because you
didn't want to do it that's great
I love memoirs they're the things in
your head that you cry about and then
put on paper make sure you include that
I killed Osama bin Laden and then I
passed the healthcare bill and then I
was the first black president coming
right up sir
you